So, what else do we want to make a report on?
>> I think it would be nice to, as a way of
gauging in the future how many V.I.P verse general admission tickets to sell.
>> That we sold over time?
>> Well, keeping track of that, so that you know maybe
for a concert in a year from now. I'll be able
to say historically this many people buy VIP and I'll be
able to sort of, you know, allocate the space appropriately or
something like that.
>> Okay.
>> So yeah, tickets over time.
>> Yeah, so that's a really similar chart to what we've already made. So we
can actually just keep using the same report and then save as at the end
>> Okay.
>> to have a completely different report. Cool.
>> So we have our grouping here already by ticket
type. But the other thing that it sounded like was really
important was the over time thing. And so, we have
that one field. What's that one field that we have on?
>> Purchase date, I think?
>> Purchase date, exactly. Yeah, so, we'll
want to group by purchase date also. And
so we can create another grouping. That
we can drag straight into our summary report.
>> Cool. Okay so let's go down to Attendee > Purchase Date.
>> Well let's think about this really quick before
dragging it in. Do you think that you'd want
to group by purchase date first? Or do you
think you'd want to group by the ticket type first?